good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-610 object
class Keter special containment
procedures due to the vast area of
infection scp-610 covers containment is
impossible isolation of the area has
proved far more effective and permission
has been granted by the russian
government to establish a perimeter to
keep people out of these areas under the
guise of military operations should any
organism displaying traits consistent
with scp-610 be sited near this
perimeter then the established protocol
requires it being gauged at range with
small arms until a mobile been
dispatched using incendiary weapons and
munitions from as great a distance as
possible any living thing coming in
physical contact with an organism
infected with a CP 610 is considered
expendable and is to be immediately
terminated and incinerated any persons
coming within 3 metres of scp-610
infected life are to immediately
withdraw from the area be isolated from
the rest of the team and subjected to
medical examination using only remote
techniques to determine if infection has
occurred at appropriate steps taken
based on that determination present the
known infection vectors of scp-610
spread seems to be focused on physical
contact drone movements with heavily
infected areas have returned air samples
containing minut particulate which one
exposed to organic compounds will result
in the spread of scp-610 the results of
these particular tests have revealed
that most requires several days to
manifest if at all with the exception of
direct contact with exposed lung and
liver tissue these particular tests show
a rapid rate of growth which requires
incineration of the testing environment
no more than 24 hours after initial
exposure even with the 2-hour mishap
risking a compromised facility event
even that this kind of rapid growth only
occurs in organic material existing
outside the human body this form of
infection is
currently considered a minor concern
these peculiarities have given rise to a
series of questions regarding the
possible origin of the infection in
conjunction with the fit containment
protocol remains at a scorched-earth
policy at this time and no concern for
transmission via water or air infection
parameters exist
barring situational changes in the field
description initial reports of scp-610
came direct from the russian government
through undisclosed about these reports
consisted primarily of disappearances of
farmers in the region and were not
considered until the local police
followed by the regional police and
finally a government dispatch agent all
failed to report within a 72 hour period
a small military contingent was
dispatched to the area and quickly
withdrew at which point the foundation
was contacted to investigate the area
scp-610 effects is close to Lake Baikal
in southern Siberia areas of known
infection are marked on the map provided
to us containment perimeters are marked
in blue surrounding these infection
areas and as a present no further
locations have been identified
incursions into the perimeter must be
reported prior to conducting confirmed
during exploration and debriefed on
immediately following return scp-610
appears to be a contagious skin disease
at first with symptoms including rash
itching and increased skin sensitivity
within three hours the disease will
cause blemishes resembling heavy scar
tissue to form in the chest and arm
areas spreading to the legs and back
within an additional hour consuming the
victim completely within five hours
exposure to high temperatures vastly
decreases the time for the contagion to
spread and complete infections have been
recorded occurring in as little as five
minutes
after the completion of the infection
occurs the victims life functions will
cease for approximately three minutes
after which time they will restart at
two to three times the activity rate of
a normal human following this the scar
tissue on the victims will start to move
of its own accord and grow at a rapid
rate normal human features start to
disappear at this point under the
infection and the path of mutation
appears to be largely random subjects
observed during this stage of infection
have been recorded as growing three or
more limbs of a type such as arms or
legs the head may become misshapen
elongate or widen out and parts of the
subject may split open from which
additional branches of flesh will grow
the duration of the stage of infection
is unknown and not all subjects appear
in to progress to the later stages under
unknown conditions an infected
individual will cease moving and place
itself in a location it deems suitable
where it roots itself the fleshy growth
on the victim will then begin to spread
across all surrounding objects and
consume them such objects do not spread
infection as living creatures do however
and the effect of prolonged contact with
these objects is recorded later in this
document it is assumed that this
behavior is to create an area hospitable
to continued growth of the other
infected observation of life infected by
scp-610 by staph is impossible those
infected with the disease immediately
seek out aid as natural human impulse
resulting in unintended infections those
infected past the scar tissue phase
actively and aggressively attempt to
infect anyone approaching them within an
undefined area it has been established
that should an infected be capable of
site and observe an uninfected it will
proceed towards them if the infected has
lost the ability of site a range of
approximately 30 metres is considered
safe
observation of scp-610 infected
settlements has been established using
artificial methods such as remote robots
the data returned from these
observations coupled with the openly
aggressive nature of the infected to
attempt to spread a CP 610 has resulted
in the kenner classification however so
long as nothing is allowed to enter or
leave the infected areas it is
considered a neutralized threat of
concern are the cavernous areas beneath
the infected settlements that were
discovered during the exploration and
attempts to get research personnel into
these areas are underway okay we will
now be going over the field logs
associated with scp-610 unfortunately at
this time scp-610 l6 has been redacted
the only thing available about this
field log is it's an exploration record
of operation source point which I've
been informed is for class-a personnel
or higher only so without further ado
this is field log scp-610 l1 small
remote controlled Rover sent to site a
to locate missing personnel after
establishing the containment perimeter
for scp-610 the russian government
approved our requests to research and
investigate the area for the first such
exploration a small camera mounted unit
known as a herbie was dispatched at a
safe distance and directed towards site
a herbie has a battery life of 12 hours
and a control range far wider than that
required for this dispatch Herbie is
able to enter site a without incident
the landscape around site a shows early
stages of assimilation by singular
scp-610 infected who have fallen at
largely random intervals around what
remains of the village many of the homes
appear to have suffered fire damage long
since put out however a fair amount
remain intact aerial reconnaissance of
sign a combined with thermal imaging has
put it at
estimated population of 79 infected a
mobile infected are included in this
number however it is difficult to
ascertain an exact percentage of mobile
versus a mobile varying degrees of
physical mutation due to scp-610 are
present in site a and it is assumed all
the inhabitants are in advanced stages
of the infection her be observed the
exterior of the village for two hours
during which time all infected behaved
with what appeared to be a loose sense
of social structure because her me
remains stationary during this
observation period it is unknown
precisely what each individual infected
person was doing however the central
plaza experienced occasional bursts of
activity and downtime requiring more
information Herbie was directed to
follow uninfected as it entered a home
there was a bumpy camera feed as Herbie
scoots over the gravel behind the
quickly shambling infected person the
interior of this home is the same as
that attached to the primary file or a
CP 610 the infected being tailed is the
one sitting at the table after entering
the home Kirby's camera was raised
slowly as to not to draw attention this
action was either unnoticed or ignored
the infected person is watched from the
doorway as it hobbles around the home
and stops at each of the other visible
infected organisms however it appears to
ignore the one under the table which
while not a mobile does not leave that
area what this creature was before
infection is unclear after lapping the
table and repeating this procedure three
times the primary infected person known
as alpha
henceforward stops at the bedridden
infected known as beta and proceeds to
assault it with furious punches it is
unable to leave the bed for unknown
reasons but it is not completely a
mobile as it flails its arms in response
to the beatings delivered by alpha after
several sustained minutes of this
beating piercing sound explodes from the
area around beta who then proceeds to
project a cloud of unknown matter into
the air from its chest cavity alpha
lingers in the cloud
as it floats in the air around them
slowly descending into the ground the
unknown life-form on the table aside
beta begins to twitch in an apparent
seizure and alpha again elapsed the room
twice more stopping again at each
infected organism but still ignoring the
one under the table as well as beta
after these two lapse alpha seats itself
at the table and reaches out to position
the three plates atop it as if setting a
dinner set after the plates are
positioned the facial tendrils extending
from Alpha wiggle up and start to coil
on one of the plates before tearing
apart and separating this is repeated at
each plate the image attached to scp-610
s primary file is a still image of this
occurrence after each plate is filled
with alphas flesh it leaves the table
and approaches Herbie which is moved
form alphas path alpha leaves the home
but Kirby's camera remains focused on
the table after several minutes a group
comprised of sixth seven infected enter
the room from outside still ignoring
Herbie each infected shambles as if
movement is difficult jerking in large
steps or squirming in small ones these
infected all surround the table in H
take turns grabbing handfuls of the
flesh substance left by alpha pressing
it into whatever orifices on themselves
they can summon two mouths some into the
chest some behind their backs some under
the arms when all the plates are empty
this group leaves
Herbie remains here for several more
minutes before attracting its camera and
leaving immediately after leaving the
home Herbie collides with an object
panning the camera around the
obstruction appears to be alpha whose
facial tendrils are intermingling with
another infected having similar
mutations the impact is ignored and the
two infected part ways after several
minutes Herbie is then directed to
explore more areas of the village
the remains of what appears to have been
in store shows signs of severe fire
damage as well as activity inside the
building which Herbie moves to
investigate the door is slightly ajar
and with firm movements of Herbie it is
pushed open no notice is taken of this
action or it is ignored inside the store
are several infected persons most of
whom are standing around however one is
on the ground rolling back and forth
over the space of approximately 0.3
meters it's about 1 foot and is ignored
by the others Herbie rolls under the
divider separating the cashier area from
the customer area and pans around behind
the counter the upper half of a person
is protruding from a cellar door behind
the counter this person does not appear
to be suffering from advanced infection
and wears the garb of a Russian soldier
Herbie zooms in the camera to confirm
identification and it is noticed the
eyes of this person are in constant
movement often focusing on Herbie the
rest of the soldier does not move Herbie
is directed to leave this area and
proceeds to the back room in this
storage area a large pile of bodies are
stacked together some pieces of clothing
are visible and appear to contain both
military garb and everyday clothing no
facial features are discernible on any
of the bodies due to the way they're
stacked top the bodies and infected sits
appearing to have its lower parts fused
to the pile and with its upper half in a
wild state of flailing and seizure
approximately every 10 seconds a burst
of spores flies out the top of this
infected which linger in the air Herbie
is directed to leave the building after
leaving this building
Herbie passes by the village well
surrounding which are a series of a
mobile infected all facing the well the
arms of each of these infected persons
are stretched out one in contact with
the next forming a perfect chain safe
for one whose arms are down at his side
Herbie passes by this last infected to
approach what appears to have been a
town hall or mayor's building when the
infected becomes mobile and snatches
there were over up the DL feed from
Herbie focuses on the thinks of the
infected which is strangely in perfect
shape given the condition of the rest of
its body which is horribly bloated this
infected was once a young girl from
appearance estimated 10 to 12 Herbie has
rolled side-to-side in its grip as its
face stares motionless at the rover
infect its face suddenly balloons in
size and explodes outward into a series
of fleshy flaps that grip Herbie and
draw it inside her bees video feed
terminates here Herbie was considered
lost at this point however no one at
control remember to turn off the video
feed assuming it cut five hours later
Herbies video feed resumed stationary
and at raised level pointing at the
upper rim of the village well the video
feed contains some blur due to what
appears to be a slimy film which often
uses across the lens but would not
obscured provides perfect quality
recording Herbie does not respond to any
remote commands but its video jerks back
and forth from target to target zooming
in and zooming out of its own accord
video feed is cut manually and all
connections to Herbie's unit are ordered
erased moving on this is field long
scp-610 l2 an infected Class D personnel
is sent in to sightsee with video
equipment
during construction of the perimeter
surrounding scp-610 s containment area
several Class D personnel were infected
due to assaults from the infected
villagers or animals roaming the area in
addition to a number of infections as a
result of escape attempts and careless
behavior most of these infected
personnel were immediately destroyed
with flamethrowers however a small
collection of infected were contained in
cold storage units which prolonged the
inevitable progression of scp-610 s
mutated properties the decision was made
to utilize some of these infected
personnel as video relays and dispatched
them to nearby sites due to the concern
over loss of equipment as evidenced in
scp-610 l1 all three subjects that were
used in this manner were sent in with a
single video system site C additional
equipment issued for this dispatch
include a 1 gallon container of gasoline
three emergency flares three
nine-millimeter pistols with three
magazines of ammunition H and three
single serving food rations the infected
personnel were instructed to observe and
avoid interaction with the infected
villagers
as long as possible but should a
situation arise where they are met with
aggression or feel they are losing
themselves to scp-610 s influence they
are free to kill as many infected
villagers as they so choose and do as
much damage to infected objects and
property as possible while maintaining
video feed the intent of this order was
to provide data of scp-610 infected
communities in a raid situation so a
plan of eradication could be better
established at the time of this
expedition site C was suspected to be a
possible origin point for scp-610 having
far fewer mobile infected than other
sites as well as structures which appear
to have been layered over several times
with the terraforming effects of the
immobile infected dispatch Class D
personnel known henceforth as di 1 di 2
and di 3 were directed to pay particular
attention to anything that could be
considered an origin point for a CP 610
the trek from our perimeter camp to
sightsee was uneventful there was no
evidence of any native animal life in
the area as sightsee has approached
there is no noticeable rise in the
temperature within the last 30 meters of
the trip that necessitates removal of
the heavy cult based coverings that were
provided the temperature rises again
sharply at the entrance to sight see
propper which requires a further
shedding of garments for fear of heat
stroke temperatures within sight senior
described as being heavily humid around
32 degrees
that's 89 Fahrenheit one of the first
immediately noticed traits of outside C
is an array of a mobile pylons which
encircle what is believed to be the
entirety of the site separated by an
apparent distance of 5 to 6 meters each
pylon appears to be two to four infected
persons fused together in one spot on
some of these pylons features such as
faces or anuses are still visible in
addition to several other holes which do
not naturally occur all appearing to act
as heat vents where the heat is
generated is unknown current belief is
that this is an advanced stage of
scp-610 terraforming in its environment
to facilitate spread of itself di 2 was
the farthest along and progression of
scp-610 of the 3 by a number of hours
begins to seizure after only a few
minutes in Site C during examination of
the pylons
the progression to the scar tissue phase
of scp-610 infection is observed in full
course as di 2 spasms on the ground his
entire body being overtaken by the
sticky tan flesh almost entirely after
45 seconds di 2 was terminated by a
gunshot from di 1 and his equipment left
where it is the spread of scp-610 over
di 2 continues even after death of the
body until all movement ceases as
perimeter control is relaying new
instructions to di 1 and di 3 regarding
the situation there is a shift in the
ground covering in sight see where di
two's body is video feed shows the
fleshlight growth splitting open beneath
his body and a series of ropey tendrils
coming from within the gap to pull his
corpse inside this opening closes up
quickly total time elapsed 3 seconds as
di 1 and di 3 decide to act quickly in
these hotter temperatures fearing the
same fate they proceed to the village
center and encounter another previously
unknown phenomenon in the precise center
of town rising above what was the
community well is a sphere suspended by
angled supports comprised of scp-610
flesh the ball is riddled with the
features of humans in early stages of
scp-610 infection as well as a good
number assumed to be in later stages a
number of specimens of non-human life
forms such as deer and bears are also
visible within the mass the entire
sphere of flesh pulses at a roughly five
second interval and with each pulse
emits a ring of Sporn like material from
its equator this material floats to the
ground and appears to be absorbed into
the converted environment di 3 begins to
douse the sphere with the provided
gasoline and when questioned by a
panicking di one explains this looks
like as good a thing to burn as any at
this point perimeter control has ceased
in giving commands due to the rapid
deterioration of events there is no
reaction from anything within sight see
to any of this activity until the
precise moment at which a lit emergency
flare is applied to the spherical mass
which immediately goes up in flames the
remote feed plays back and knows from an
unknown location that seems to come from
a location far outside of sight see what
was reported as being heard even at
perimeter control but
site C and a the noise described as both
explosive as if multiple high-yield
charges were detonated on a mountainside
and alive like a large feral creature
roaring within 15 seconds following this
sounds dissipation site a reported that
a series of explosions had occurred
within the village five seconds after
this report the spherical mass in the
middle of Site C explodes di 1 and di 3
are thrown by the blast di 3 is
confirmed deceased by di 1 after
regaining his footing having suffered
injury from stone shrapnel from the wall
di 1 is able to report he has bruises
and ringing ears but aside from the
rapidly spreading scp-610 infection he
suffered no blast damage during this
recording of footage di 1 had his video
equipment removed and was looking into
it due to the angle of recording it is
unknown precisely what occurred in Site
C but something draws di one's attention
back to the centre of town where he
stares for several moments and is then
pulled in the opposite direction the
video equipment falling to the ground
recording in a skyward direction the
last moments of footage from di ones
video unit display a humanoid figure
moving through the air followed by the
sound of an impact in the same direction
within 3 seconds of this event an
unknown creature steps upon the
recording video equipment and destroys
it perimeter control remained on high
alert for a full 24 hours at all
locations without any incident following
this event and moving on to field log
scp-610 l 3 initial discovery of the
tunnel entrances at site a the
destruction caused by the rapid collapse
of the site see exploration attempt
during scp-610 L 2 resulted in a series
of unexpected events in sign a as the
strange spherical formation in Site C
was burned and destroyed the scp-610
infected inhabiting site a were recorded
by aerial drones going into seizure
and convulsions the immobilize a P six
ten infected rapidly shriveled and died
along with all of the flesh materials
spread across inanimate objects within
the village the mobile scp-610 infected
who were able to regain their footing
all proceeded to what appears to have
formerly been an upper class residence
and entered the building as the infected
entered this dwelling it suffered a
foundational collapse revealing the
presence of a sinkhole beneath it the
size of the hole in relation to the
structure above it post an impossibility
for an entire building to collapse
suggesting something within the hole
applied force directly to the structure
with the intent to pull it inside and
expose the hole the revealed hole is
approximately large enough to
accommodate three grown men standing
shoulder-to-shoulder light sources
applied by remote drones failed to
penetrate further than four meters depth
into the whole objects dropped into the
hole did not produce an impact sound
suggesting a bottom potentially more
than a thousand meters down research of
the exterior of the site a hole was only
able to be carried out for two hours at
a time
samples of the atmosphere inside a
indicated a complete death of scp-610
related materials all infectious life
that did not evacuate into the hole died
above-ground and quickly became
shriveled husks manned exploration of
sign a was approved and commenced
immediately in the span of 30 minutes a
total of three research teams consisting
of two to three research staff and four
to five armed escort each were
dispatched and setting up stations
within the remains of the village
samples of deceased scp-610 infected and
converted manner were sent back to
perimeter HQ for processing and
transport one team was able to recover a
small sample of still living scp-610
tissue substance from the building and
packet for research within the second
hour of exploration of site a series of
echo reverberation units were set up
surrounding the hole with the intent of
getting an accurate mapping of the hole
impossible
tunnels at the end of the second hour
before the echo units could be activated
seismic activity began to occur within
sight a two teams of the original three
remained on site the third on route back
to perimeter HQ with samples the third
team was instructed to proceed back to
perimeter HQ when seismic activity began
and we're told that site a should not be
returned to for assistance
seismic activity at site a capped at a
2.3 Richter level before P tearing off
immediately following the seismic event
a torrent of scp-610 spores erupted from
the hole and layered the area around it
for a span of 50 metres as all staff on
site were in level a hazardous material
suits the spore burst was startling but
did not lead to any infections as the
eruption was being reported both teams
at site a came under attack from aerial
life-forms infected with a CP 6:10 these
organisms were captured by the remote
drone video equipment and showed
extremely advanced stages of infection
it is impossible to tell what they
mutated from to this present state many
of the avian creatures attacked by
splitting their heads in half and
clamping them against research members
pulling them into the air and dropping
them into the hole and possible these
avian infected proved vulnerable to
small arms fire in dispatching them a
total of two research staff were lost to
the hole and one injured due to
crossfire the injured staff was put down
immediately upon showing signs of
infection due a suit breach
before video and radio contact was lost
with the remaining teams inside site a a
second seismic event began to occur
starting out in the 1 to 1.5 range and
scale attention was directed at the hole
to prepare for a second assault a second
spore burst erupted from the hole during
the rising seismic activity at the point
where scales registered a 3 to 3.5 and
force a new unseen scp-610 entity began
to emerge from the hole the only footage
captured of this creature depicts an
engorged human head approximately 20
times larger than normal pressing itself
out of the hole with no discernible body
video and radio contact were lost as
seismic forces increased to 7 on the
scale for 2 seconds duration then
abruptly ceased further aerial
surveillance of the site a hole an area
depict zero activity and no traces of
the research teams or their ever having
been there all personnel and equipment
are considered lost the next field log
is scp-610 l4 unmanned exploration of
the site 8 tunnels events regarding the
discovery research and handling of
scp-610 rapidly degraded to a point work
failsafe options were being considered
for over 1 hour nothing further had
happened at site a following the loss of
the research teams during the seismic
events in scp-610 l3 and subsequent
contact with previously unseen scp-610
life-forms with the absence of activity
at site a a remote drone dispatch was
authorized in two parts the first part
would drop a remote relay device at the
entrance to the site a sinkhole and the
second part would dispatch it drone into
the hole directly to relay its data to
the remote relay for transmission back
to HQ drones on site were powered by
solar energy with a battery maintaining
a four hour charge
attached is the video log recovered from
the site a sinkhole drone before its
loss video feed activates researchers
faces scene looking into the camera
applying a polishing cloth to the lens
quote this is explorative drone are
scp-610 - one coming online systems
check out video confirmed feed is good
to relay station we are testing rotors
now and deploying is successful in the
sound of the helicopter blade starts up
as video feed begins to lift in the air
camera tilts left and right to test pan
features then directs itself towards the
site a sinkhole quote video feed is go
engines are go links are green alright
sending drone down now in quote audio
from the outside world fades away as the
camera angles itself down and peers into
the darkness within the sinkhole after
approximately two minutes of descent
lights on the drone activate and
illuminate a roughly dug shaft initially
it is unclear what could have created
the hole but at a glance it would appear
that the shaft was created by a single
event rather than dug over time at 15
meters descent there are traces of
scp-610 material attached to the dirt
and stuck to rocks the material is
dormant but retains its texture and
appearance
unlike samples from above ground level
which shrivel and dry rap
there is a possible connection with this
material and the events last recorded
during scp-610 l-3 descent continues at
a hundred meters in depth branch tunnels
become visible in the walls of the
sinkhole panning of the camera reveals
small tunnels branching out apparently
at random intervals but which are not
restricted to any one side of the hole
these tunnels are considered too small
for any useful exploration to occur
descent continues increase in density of
scp-610 materials on walls is noted as
depth increases at 250 meters the bottom
of the sinkhole becomes visible and the
tunnel slopes sharply suggesting a
natural formation which was already
suspected drone video shifts to
illuminate this tunnel and drone
proceeds forward through the area
scp-610 COEs entirety of the tunnel now
and care is taken to keep the drone from
coming into contact with any surface
movement is detected five meters ahead
lights on the drone are dimmed and
weapons come online the are scp-610
drone is equipped with a 5.56 millimeter
machine gun containing 50 rounds of
ammunition this is meant to be used to
deter wildlife away from the drone and
defend against aggression went possible
rather than to dispatch a target
although it is fully capable of handling
human aggressors in small groups camera
focus turns to the moving mass of flesh
ahead at 3 metres after focus clears the
movement appears to be coming from what
appears to be a deer uninfected
wriggling in the grips of tendrils
composed of scp-610 material deer is
being suspended above the ground with
unclear intent the drone is moved to
pass the trapped deer while holding an
envy of the camera until safely away
nothing occurs with the deer and the
drone proceeds past
undisturbed the previously fairly level
ground of the tunnels displays large
humps in apparently random placement
five meters ahead of the drone thirty
meters past the encountered deer upon
approach these lumps turn out to be
similar to the infected villagers who
escaped from site a into the sinkhole
after the destruction of site c the
sound of rushing water is now detected
and the drone is pushed forward a
hundred meters further into the tunnel
the sound of running water is now
deafening drone lights reveal a running
stream of water potentially from one of
the adjacent rivers in the area a sample
file is placed in the water allowed to
collect and then released with an active
tracking beacon later recovery of this
sample indicates no scp-610
contamination of ground water the tunnel
splits in two at this point one tunnel
leads around the river and then seems to
slope downward while the other is
directly above the light source in the
ceiling the second one is selected to
facilitate recovery of the drone during
adjustment of the drones flight path it
comes in contact with a portion of the
tunnel wall coated in scp-610 causing a
deep gash from the propeller of the
drone which is already healing over when
the camera focuses on the impact point
the drone proceeds upwards 300 meters of
upwards travel taking approximately 45
minutes results in the drone emerging
into a windy section of mountain where
it is directed to stay low camera
panning of the area reveals what may
have once been a village long since
abandoned the precise location is
unclear but it is assumed to be in the
vicinity of site B judging from
estimates in travel by the drone the
buildings here are coated in deceased
layers of scp-610 and unlike other
buildings in site a and site C which
were coated at scp-610
these buildings appear to be constructed
directly from the tissue substance after
a cursory scan of site B it is
determined there is no life here either
natural or scp-610 related so the drone
is directed back into the tunnel as the
winds around the area make aerial
recovery impossible upon descent into
the tunnel a deep roaring sound fills
the audio and video feed becomes choppy
as something blocks the signal during
periods in which connection to the drone
is clearest its camera and weapon are
angled downward and propellers slow and
speed to allow a faster drop video feed
becomes entirely clear for the final two
minutes before feed is lost rushing up
toward the drone from the area below is
what appears to be a large human face
stretch to 20 times its proportions with
no features save those created by the
scp-610 material there are eyesockets
but no eyes a mouth but no teeth the
drone fires upon this rushing mass of
scp-610 but the bullets do not deter it
impact points remain invisible for
several seconds before closing over
themselves there was no room in the
tunnel for the drone to take evasive
action and it is swallowed by the mass
our scp-610 is considered lost until
three hours later when the feed
inexplicably returns video feed from the
drone appears to show a series of
structures illuminated by one of the two
lights of the drone the camera pans
around without instructions from the
remote relays or HQ capturing a vast
number of shambling entities within the
area a cp6 the material moves over the
lens of the drone and video feed is
permanently severed
manned exploration was approved results
are in field log scp-610 l5 manned
exploration of the site eight tunnels
approval from central HQ was granted for
a man to salt excursion into the tunnels
beneath site a to try to ascertain the
extent of the scp-610 infection the
destruction of site a and site C have
established scp-610 can be contained and
destroyed making the source of the
infection top priority
the initial descent into the tunnels
consists of five teams to research and
three assault along with enough
equipment to establish an underground
base of operations descent into the
tunnels was established using pulley
systems and a lift to move equipment
assault teams were the first to descend
armed with flame units to clean a CP 610
out of the area all teams were able to
descend without incident and flame units
took point providing an undisturbed
journey toward the water source where
the are scp-610 drone was lost base camp
for underground scp-610 operations
resides at the bottom of a three-way
junction for if the water flow is
included the first pathway is that which
led from site a to cavern HQ the second
is the pathway to the ruined village
residing in the mountains above where
our scp-610 was destroyed by a large
unknown scp-610 entity the third pathway
heads west and seems to follow the flow
of the water for an unknown distance the
cavern area here is quite large and is
supported by a number of rock formations
that are coated with decayed scp-610
material the state of this material
suggests great age and appears to
reinforce the structural supports
whether or not this is intentional or
coincidental is unknown the two research
teams split activities between building
cavern HQ and collecting samples of
scp-610 in various states no contagious
materials were detected within this area
and the creature recorded by unmanned
drones did not appear at any point to
the cavern staff of the four research
teams three were ordered to proceed down
the unexplored pathway while an aerial
drone was prepped for a second recon of
the vertical shaft scp-610 infection did
not appear in the third pathway until
approximately three kilometers and
serious infection did not appear until
16 kilometers in even after the lengths
traveled by the assault teams no scp-610
infectious life-forms were encountered
and the fleshy material coating the
cavern walls posed no threat to the team
the most significant reports at this
time were the increasing thickness of
the material suggesting a source and the
complete lack of scp-610 contamination
in the water as a test a sample of
scp-610 was cut away from the cavern
wall and placed in the flow of the water
it exhibited no unusual reactions but
was quickly swept away by the current at
twenty kilometers in the leader of the
assault teams requested a transport
buggy to be dispatched to them one was
available at above-ground HQ however it
would take time to move it to cavern HQ
and then remote drive it to the team's
rations provided to the assault teams
were sufficient so a camp was
established while the buggy was moved
and readied
during this time an aerial drone was
also sent to explore the vertical shaft
the results of this exploration were
placed on hold with the arrival of the
buggy at cavern HQ and ultimately
concluded in document the buggy was
navigated to the assault team encampment
with no events on route however upon
arrival and preparation to continue the
exploration the assault teams came under
attack by a number of large scp-610
infected life-forms that emerged from
the area ahead of them video recovered
from the assault team cameras show them
caught off guard as scp-610 infected
made no sound and were undetectable on
one film for one to two seconds it
appears that some of the creatures are
coming out of the scp-610 materials on
the wall not emerging from them so much
is being created by the material and
they're breaking away to act
independently during this assault an
attempt to protect the buggy members
were lost to the water currents and
contact with them was lost contact was
regained however and is recorded in
scp-610 l6 the remainder of the assault
team now consisted of three members
armed with a single flame unit use of
this unit to repel the assault proved
vital has standard firearms did minimal
damage to the infected creatures these
infected creatures show minimal traits
to associate them with any known form of
life in the region giving rise to the
belief that they may have been spawned
by the scp-610 infection itself as a
form of defense no further casualties
were suffered during the raid and the
remaining members managed to eliminate
all attacking infected
allowing them to continue with
exploration with added orders to attempt
to locate lost team members a further 20
kilometers into the tunnel the river
separated from the tunnel pathway and
the team was instructed to abandon the
recovery order given the inability to
navigate the waters safely a total time
passed before the remaining assault team
reached an end in the tunnel at the
perimeter of the area now known as sight
beam the team came under assault again
from a smaller number of scp-610 that
were much larger in size these infected
appeared in the tunnel as if they were
lying in wait for the approaching team
these creatures were dispatched using
the flame unit although all fuel for the
unit was expended in this act the
assault team was now limited to standard
weapons and short-range personal flame
units a time-lapse of five minutes is
allowed to pass before the team proceeds
further into sight be cautious of
further assaults by scp-610 infected the
tunnel widens out into what appears to
have once been a village of intermediate
age the construction of the buildings in
this area are primitive compared to the
settlements at site a and site C and are
clearly of human construction many of
the buildings rest at angles or slants
suggesting that they were disturbed by a
cave-in of interest is a building that
appears to be a church with a working
clock tower this building is built atop
the remains of two older buildings that
have fallen completely and has a visibly
stable foundation surrounding all
structures in this area is a depression
in the ground filled with a substance
resembling a liquefied form of scp-610
fleshy materials the pool moves as if
acted upon by my new tent unseen forces
rippling outward from invisible contact
points and rolling in waves from on felt
wins the team avoids this pool at all
time
and proceeds through the ruins slowly
unstable foundations who are possible
making the church their target area
within the church are pews as would be
expected however there are only four one
of them shattered when the building
could accommodate as many as 20 the
three intact pews were arranged in a 2:1
formation facing a pulpit there is no
trace of dust on any surface the entire
area appearing to be immaculately clean
given the location and believed age
behind the pulpit is a hole in the floor
exposing an area of the scp-610 pool
beneath the building the church and
ruins appear to be uninhabited an
exploration of the church proper is
uneventful until the clock tower Bell
Tolls this tolling triggers a shudder in
the building followed by human screams
from the ceiling lights Shawn upon the
ceiling reveal a large mass of scp-610
from which descend a series of six
wooden circles strapped to each circle
is a living human coated entirely from
neck to toe and scp-610 but having an
exposed head which appears uninfected
these human captives scream as the Bell
continues to toll and the circles move
to the ground the team begins to move
toward one to investigate when an
unknown creature cries from outside the
building prompting them to take cover in
the shadows near the pulpit the light
sources are extinguished itching the
entire area into darkness night vision
is left off to avoid revealing the
team's location the sounds continue to
emit from outside of the church drawing
closer but lower than the frantic
screams of the captive humans at least
one noticed the team as the captive
humans often call out to be saved from
the entrance to the church the candle
lights on the side of the doorway then
one on the other side figure is seen
holding a small torch and moving back
and forth between a series of candles to
light the doorway
the flame is then applied to a rope
coated in scp-610 which quickly ignites
and spreads up to a peculiar chandelier
system at the church entrance the light
from this system illuminates most of the
crosses but does not reach the team's
hiding place those captives who appear
in the light
do not show standard signs of the
beige-colored scp-610 infection but
instead are wrapped in a red variant of
it which shows signs of constant motion
rippling across itself in waves from
outside the church a flood of a-c-p 610
infected shambled quickly into the area
ignoring the man who lit the candles and
stands in the middle of the room they
proceed to the captives on the wooden
circles and begin to pull at the red
scp-610 masses resulting in further
screams and cries from what can be
gathered from the return video feed the
red scp-610 seems to be connected to the
captives and is using them as a source
of sustenance that it then uses to grow
and feed the normal scp-610 infected
overly zealous infected tear at the red
mass too hard which results in pulling
skin and tissue from the human captive
beneath this exposed area is quickly
covered over by the red mass which then
grows in size feeding like this
continues for approximately six minutes
at which time the candle baring figure
sounds a gong and all infected entities
moved to the pews there are several more
creatures than seats but none move past
the front most pews the figure-4 sound
of the gong does not move spontaneously
collapsing as if made from hollow clay
from the pulpit area activity is noticed
as a pillar of scp-610 flesh rises
through the hole and extends directing
itself toward the gathered creatures no
sound is heard and no motion is recorded
once the pillar stops moving
the silent period persists for ten
minutes without even the human captives
making a sound having fallen silent at
an unknown point the pillar of scp-610
retracts back into the hole it emerged
from without any warning prompting the
departure of the infected from the
building the candles remain lit and the
team emerges after all infected appear
to leave the area that ascended captives
remain at ground level as well
all screaming seeming to have ceased but
still showing signs of life with heavy
breathing and movement upon departure
from the church camera feeds from all
three members became erratic camera one
ceases transmitting completely camera
two shoots straight up into the air for
several metres camera three captures the
member with camera two being flown by a
tendril that emerges out of the ground
itself swinging them out of sight on to
the other side of the ruins camera ones
feed is restored and displays camera
threes owner running briefly in the
direction of the lost team member only
to turn and run back as scp-610 infected
pour from between buildings combat
ensues between the two members and the
onrushing infected using assault rifles
and personal flame units successfully
driving back enough of the Horde to make
an escape towards the buggy passing by a
building camera once owners ambushed by
a figure resembling the figure who was
in the church lighting candles wielding
a large crop sighs camera threes owner
continues without pause towards the
buggy location however the buggies found
half absorbed by the scp-610 mass
covering the floor while turning to find
another way of escape camera threes
owner turns to find the same figure with
the scythe approaching weapon raised two
shots are fired and the camera feed
ends five hours later while final
decisions were underway to decide how to
contain or eradicate the scp-610 threat
time-delayed video feed from the lost
team members who fell into the
underground river currents was
established has been filed in scp-610 l6
as I said at the start of this lecture
scp-610 l6 has been redacted and is only
viewable by class-a personnel or higher
thank you very much for listening and
that concludes today's lecture thank you
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you